hey i'm dave rubin welcome to the rubin
report and this week we have a meaty
show for you we got info we got facts
there is a lot going on in the world you
know sometimes they say it's a slow news
week slow news day not this week a lot
happening and I got two great guests for
you first off comedy legend can I call
you comedy legend will you accept it
miss Elaine Boosler look in the Bigfoot
manner yes whatever matter yes in the
Loch Ness monster spirit I will accept
the legend comedy legend Elaine bizarre
one of my favorite ladies and tyt legend
I can call you that can I not miss okay
I'll take it the Bigfoot way the news
anchor way anyway ana kasparian yay I
love doing this show so I'm excited and
leave I've heard a lot about you so I'm
very excited about hosting with you well
say my using hosting I keep going into
that habit but guesting with you testing
where we can switch spots we'll do a
little round robin I think we can each
take a topic and see what it'd be like
you know tennis we'll just rotate yeah
okay exactly all right well this is
YouTube so we got to get to it fast
alright so too as I said this has been a
big news week and today's just Monday
craziness is happening so the doj the
Department of Justice it has come out
that they have obtained two months of
phone records from the AP that is the
Associated Press and people are going
bonkers and by the time we get this to
you tomorrow we may have a whole set of
new facts so we're going to talk about
in a kind of wide-ranging way but
basically they took these records
without anyone knowing now it's coming
out that maybe some of the higher-ups
did know and the AP released a statement
about it let's take a look at that this
is from the AP president and CEO Gary
Pruitt he said there can be no possible
justification for such an over there can
be no possible justification for such an
over broad collection of telephone
communications of the associated press
and its reporters these records
potentially reveal communications with
confidential sources across all of the
news gathering activities undertaken by
the AP during a two-month period provide
a row map to the APS news
during operations and disclose
information about the APS activities and
operations that the government has no
conceivable right to know okay pretty
heavy stuff but you're laughing already
tape well I I can't wait to hear some
like light-hearted humor about this
because it's something that really of
course rubs me the wrong way is a member
of the press you know you don't want to
know that the government or you don't
want to hear that the government can
come in and just take two months worth
of records from journalists and
reporters now from what we're hearing at
this point is that it has to do with a
march 2012 article that was written
about the seat yet CIA finding out about
an al-qaeda plot to attack the US with
an airline right so they were able to
figure it out and make sure that that
terrorist attack never went through
which sounds like pretty good reference
of our CIA all that sounds good but
doesn't get to the heart of the problem
does it yeah I guess it doesn't get to
the heart of the problem which is
probably the reason why they want to get
access to the records and figure out who
the sources are why is it that the APA
or the AP had sources who was the source
and what other type of information is
that source sharing with media yeah so
whether they're doing something good or
not should the government be allowed of
course not and if you remember after 911
they were supposedly listening for
chatter on you know alleged people on
lists but it turned out they were
listening to everyone they were
listening at Tom Cruise make love to his
fiancee and they were they were outside
of buildings listening to celebrity so
it's this shouldn't be so outrageous for
people as a new thing it's not a new
thing and people are outraged now
because it's them they're the people
used to report on it but now it's them
well done Elayne Boosler you got to my
second point that is the part that's
driving me crazy about this because
although I think this is horrific and
the government shouldn't be spying on us
and citizens much less the reporters and
that whole thing the media is outraged
now because it's the media's because
just last week it was shown that the
Department of Justice has already said
without warrants they can go into our
emails into our chats in our
Facebook's so in a way though is this
possibly good because finally the media
is gone oh well you can't come and step
on us so it's only good if they can back
them off I don't think that anything's
gonna back them off I mean once and I
you know people say leave Bush alone you
know I'm still blaming Reagan it's still
current to me george bush but you know
you elected not you but certain folks
elected government who had no feelings
about privacy and and nothing was sacred
and overstepped in every possible
direction this is the the stepchild of
it this is the upshot and this is what
we're left with and if people don't
start voting better this is what we
gonna have yeah and I would kill someone
if I found out they were eavesdropping
on be embarrassing how many nights did
she order pizza out this position ever
cook chinese pizza this woman has never
cooked this world just a
five-thousand-dollar stove disgusting
she's a horrible person it's more about
the shame they leverage yeah right a lot
of people you think it's about like
naked pictures no food and i'm always
ordering extra soda so we'll think
there's not just me alone even although
I its hair how many pairs of chopsticks
well if you have to ask I better say
four I don't want them listening to my
damn phone call those freedoms at stake
in there excellent point and also keep
in mind that the media was really what
pushed the narrative after 911 about how
it's important for the government to
have access to certain records and it's
important for the government to do
certain things that might violate our
privacy because it's in the name of
national security so now as you
mentioned a really great point yeah the
tables turn and they can't they can't
handle it it only come to this I mean it
was the original statement you know he
who gives up a little bit of security a
little bit of privacy for a little bit
of security deserves neither and now we
have a lot more than losing a little bit
of privacy and a little bit of security
you guys do you guys fear that because
obviously the media and us that are on
the progressive side of this thing we
like let's say Obama more than we like
let's say Bush that there's this
inherent feeling that we should go easy
on him
okay not good how dare they when it
comes to civil liberties I mean Obama's
record has been just as bad if not worse
than bushes can you say drone yeah drone
strikes signature strikes where you
don't even know if you're targeting the
right person but you still do it anyway
and then when you do double taps where
you do a drone strike and then you have
you know the first responders show up
and then you drone them I mean come on
Obama has been horrible when it comes to
civil liberties kill this lack of
transparency I think that we should open
trials and being able to kill American
citizens if if they're declared an enemy
of the country and they're American
citizens due processes due process your
next you cannot stand for this and it
has to change and he resigned the
Patriot Act yeah just wish it led to all
this right and get some how we still
there's a feeling like oh that's bush's
fault all bush's forward so social
animal but it's Obama's baby now and he
was supposed to close it yeah you knows
too much going on that's wrong and you
know where look I'd always rather have
Obama than the other side in there for
so many social reasons yeah but but he's
not you know the great Savior there's a
lot that's wrong and people need to
speak up it's never over and that's the
really difficult thing about Obama you
know he is great when it comes to social
issues you want to support him because
of the fact that he did come out in
support of gay marriage and you know he
isn't anti-choice and and all that is
really important but our national
security is also very important and the
way that he's been handling it I think
puts us at more risk because it's
creating hostility toward the u.s. right
where they didn't expect it at least
they expected it from bush where they
didn't accept great point made that if
they went after the Boston terrorists
the way they go after terrorists in
Pakistan with the drone strike 500
people around in the grandstands of the
marathon would have been killed also and
we would have said as we always do well
you know that's collateral damage but we
got the guys we needed to get it's
unacceptable it's unacceptable so
speaking about acceptable my final point
on this i was watching CNN today and
Wolf Blitzer who I I become just
merciless with this guy because he is a
robot sitting in a giant computerized
room he said that you know to take the
other side of this what if the
government was tracking al-qaeda and
then quote or whoever
that's what he said I'll cable or
whoever and I'll be like like I'm Avon
ladies Elayne Boosler crossing me
ordering pizza or your mom but doesn't
this I or whoever that's pretty broad
yeah doesn't this show like how dot like
that wasn't afraid what's gonna happen
here is that because the media dumbs
everything down to the point where or
whoever who's who's whoever everybody
else which me brings us back to the
point we all agree on no yeah yeah can't
do this no no Lenovo's is the official
outfitter of the Ruben report I want to
put you in this shirt go to bonobos com
enter code TR are 20 for twenty percent
off your first purchase